طيب الان من الفن للصحه وتحديدا لكورونا
اللي ما عم تعرف الصين بصراحه ترتاح منه
والظاهر انه راح يرجع ياثر عليها
شوفوك كثيره كانت عم بتدور حول اذا كانت
البدايات اللي عم بتقدمها الصين او
البيانات اللي عم بتقدمها الصين حول
الاصابات هي صحيحه ام لا والموضوع شكل
مخاوف عندي كثير من دول العالم الولايات
المتحده اللي قالت انها عم تدرس فرض
اجراءات جديده متعلقه بكرونا على الوافدين
من الصين
عموما مش بس الولايات المتحده اتجهت نحو
هذه الخطوه اليابان والهند وماليزيا كمان
اعلنت تكثيف القواعد للوافدين من الصين
وسبب اكيد طبعا زياده الاصابات بفارس
كورونا هناك البيان او عفوا اليابان قالت
انها راح تطلب من الوافدين تقديم فحص سلبي
للفايروس بي وقت فرضت ماليزيا اجراءات
اكثر للرصد والمتابعه بس يا جماعه الموضوع
بالصين مش بهذه السهوله اكيد في
المستشفيات هناك ودور الجنازات بالفعل عم
بتوجه ضغوطات كبيره بسبب زياده انتشار
الفايروس وكمان ما بدنا ننسى انه الصحف
الاجنبيه حكت من الاسبوع او من حوالي
اسبوع عن نقص الكبير اللي صاير بالدواء
بسبب كثره الطلب عليه فالموضوع عن جد ممكن
انه يشكل خطر على الصين